foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones video
in this video I will be discussing the
major news announced by HBO that's right
my friends we have a major announcement
from HBO regarding the new Game of
Thrones show that has already been given
a green light it says HBO and Game of
Thrones has officially ordered a Duncan
egg series and I think this breaking
news is about to have the Game of
Thrones fandom on fire HBO Max has
officially green LED Another Game of
Thrones show which they are naming a
night of the Seven Kingdoms the Hedge
Knight with Author George RR Martin on
board as a series writer now let me say
that again HBO is making a series about
the night of the Seven Kingdoms with
Author George RR Martin on board as a
series writer this is absolutely
incredible The Game of Thrones Empire is
expanding once again the network
streaming service now called Max has
officially ordered to series a new show
a night of the Seven Kingdoms the Hedge
Knight the name is based on George R
Martin's successful Duncan egg novellas
which Chronicle the story of dunk the
future commander of the kingsguard sir
Duncan the tall and egg the Future King
aegon Targaryen as they wander Westeros
having Adventures roughly 100 years
before the events of the novels the show
is the second series to officially get
ordered following House of the Dragon
now the description of this new show
says a century before the events of Game
of Thrones two unlikely Heroes wander
Westeros a young naive but courageous
Knight sir Duncan the tall and his
Squire egg set in a age when a Targaryen
line still holds the iron throne and the
memory of The Last Dragon has not yet
faded from living memory great Destinies
powerful foes and dangerous exploits all
await these improbable and incomparable
friends George RR Martin himself will be
writing on the show with the author
build as an executive producer and
writer alongside House of the Dragon
producer Ira Parker It also says House
of the Dragon showrunner Ryan Condell
will work on the show as well along with
George RR Martin's longtime business
manager Vince Gerard artists the series
represents a different kind of Westeros
story than Game of Thrones or House of
the Dragon now the other shows are a
sweeping War epics was sprawling
Ensemble casts that take place in
multiple locations the Duncan egg
novellas are more intimate two-handers
with a bit of a lighter tone the name of
the series also suggests another show in
the wolf in the Cub genre of a protector
in Ward wandering a dangerous landscape
in the wake of HBO's Success With The
Last of Us and Disney's The Mandalorian
the move follows the hugely successful
launch of House of the Dragon last year
which generated nearly 30 million
viewers each episode according to HBO
well there you have it ladies and
gentlemen this breaking news is amazing
and I certainly was not expecting HBO to
drop a bombshell like this the fact that
George R Martin is writing on this show
has me very excited as well I have to
assume this Duncan egg series will be
another Smash Hit for HBO now I do hope
this means George R Martin is nearly
finished with the wins of winter because
he said he wants to get that done first
before doing anything else he said he
was about three-fourths of the way done
when he gave his last update but that
was a few months ago it does make me
wonder how far along he is now I also
wonder what this means for the other
Game of Thrones shows like the one about
Jon Snow and more recently the series
about aegon and his sisters will HBO
still focus on those now that Duncan egg
already has a green light I'm not so
sure but we shall see as always I will
make sure to keep you up to date on any
and all information regarding the Game
of Thrones and A Song of Ice and Fire
Universe I feel like HBO is just getting
started after the massive amount of
success House of the dragon's first
season had like I said in my last video
The Game of Thrones fandom is about to
get a hell of a lot more interesting and
exciting everyone thought Game of
Thrones would fall off after the ending
of the original show but this story
still has so much more to offer we are
back ladies and gentlemen back with a
vengeance let me know what all of you
think about this new information down
below are you excited for Duncan egg or
are you more interested in one of their
other shows leave me some your thoughts
once again I have to thank all of you
for watching another video I hope all of
you have a great day I will see you
again very soon bye
foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over
till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in
House of the Dragon update video well my
friends the day is finally here HBO has
officially confirmed House of the Dragon
has begun filming for its second season
for those of you who don't know they
have been sharing this information all
over their social media they even gave
us our first look of the Iron Throne set
as filming is underway as you can see
House of the Dragons verified account
says it's time to go back to King's
Landing the second season of House of
the Dragon is now in production we
should start to see a hell of a lot more
photos and videos from their sets now
that filming has finally begun and as
I've always said before I will be here
releasing videos on everything that
happens during the making of the new
season this is when new information will
start to come out every day now that
everyone is back on set I will be
looking forward to discussing all the
new photos and videos that will leak out
from the sets as they're filming the
second season make sure you have already
subscribed in order to stay up to date
because there will be a lot more videos
heading your way now deadline's new
article says let them breathe fire
production has begun on House of the
Dragon season 2. filming is underway on
the HBO show at Warner Brothers Studios
leavesden with a first look photo
released of the Iron Throne sitting in
the Great Hall of the red key Ryan
Condell who is the co-creator and
showrunner said House of the Dragon has
returned we are thrilled to be shooting
again with members of our original
family as well as new talents on both
sides of the camera all of your favorite
characters will soon be conspiring at
the council tables marching with their
armies and riding their dragons into
battle get ready for the Game of Thrones
universe and fandom the shift gears as
we head into the second season although
we still have to wait until next summer
to see the show this is when things get
exciting and interesting again as new
information releases every day now we
already saw HBO's official photo from
the set of the Iron Throne however this
isn't the first image I've seen from the
new season we got our first glimpse of
one of the massive sets only a few days
ago over on Reddit fan thanks to some
sneaky photographer they snapped a few
shots of one of the castles that will be
featured in House of the dragon's second
season now I happen to think this is
most likely the red keep in King's
Landing however there are some fans who
believe this might be another location
in Westeros I saw some fans saying this
might be Winterfell or harrenhal or even
rook's rest either way this was actually
our first look at what's happening
behind the scenes at House of the Dragon
soon enough we will see dragons flying
high overhead as the dance of the
Dragons finally begins get ready my
friends because all hell is about to
break loose this season as once again
everyone fights over the Iron Throne let
me know down below whose side are you on
the blacks or the greens also let me
know what you think about the new photos
and how excited you are for the filming
to begin on the new season as always I
want to thank everyone for watching this
video I hope all of you have a great day
I will see you again very soon bye
thank you
foreign